he loves me so much he got up before
noon today he's michael wilbon pardon
the interruption co-host
and nba analyst good morning mike
dan yes you know before noon that's
reserved for
select few as you you know me well for a
lot of years
what is your number one story tonight on
pardon the interruption do you know that
now
you know what i have not talked to
anybody but it's got to be annanovi
unless unless you know dan we gotta say
unless right because the
events overtake today so look college
football can have events that overtake
today
um and if there's news i mean real news
not not these things that
every network puts down as breaking news
which are you know most of the time
you know not you know not breaking news
um i
i i think where i sit now it's annanovi
but i
reserved the right to you know uh find
out
at 3 40 eastern time
that things have happened and like i
said college football obviously
the place where college football college
football is in a place
where it could dominate the news any
given day it ain't gonna be adrian
pete's it's just not that anymore
adrian peterson being released or going
away or going somewhere else
that could have been the big news five
years ago not anymore and it ain't earl
thomas
so it's no we're not an nfl centric show
um
like so many so i think it's going to be
an inoby and that shot
and the continuing drama of the nba
playoffs i think
i was wondering this uh last night when
i knew you were going to come on
and i wondered where did the hot take
start like did you and tony
unintentionally come up with hot takes
when you started pardon the interruption
no not in a bad way but just no i know
what you mean
dan i think and you were there for the
beginning of this i was with you for the
beginning of this a lot i just think it
evolved like it's like our conversations
when you know when you and i and john
barry were sitting around or you and i
and scotty
i mean they they're they're passionate
opinions
oh my god i hate the phrase hot takes i
i know you i know you didn't mean it in
that way in terms of this discussion
i hate it because it sounds trumped up
like when pti started there were there
were people that said do you
are you guys going to think of this as
remember that show on cnn crossfire
where the producer would call you and
see what you thought before they booked
you
right and so no we we thought of it more
as siskel and ebert i mean these are
opinions we had if we agreed we agreed
if we didn't we didn't
like i think tony and i probably agree
i don't know i'm going to say 60 to 70
percent of the time
we we get there loudly
and differently but i no
no we didn't we didn't like we hear the
word hot takes and both of us just start
shaking our heads
but i like yesterday you had richard
jefferson
who came out and said that uh the greek
freak is scottie pippen yeah
yeah um which if he was up two games to
none
is the greek freak still scottie pippen
you know that that was my thought like
he's down
0-2 well now he's scottie pippen if he
was up 2-0 he's michael jordan
and then you had jay williams then
follow up and go
you know lebron he was pippin to dwayne
wade's michael jordan
do they do they really believe those
things
you know what this is just a great
question um
i and knowing both those guys i mean i
i don't think richard ever trumps up
anything i think he tells you what he
believes he's really straight not that
and not that jay will is it but i think
they have come along particularly jay
who's
a little bit younger than richard no
they're probably yeah a little bit
younger
i think they've come along they've grown
up in the culture
dan at a time in which these things are
packaged
because they have grown accustomed to
speaking about sports
like you can tag something else along
how about numbers you and i would not
at any point in the first 20 years of
our careers ever
started a discussion of a baseball game
with war
or any any number we just wouldn't have
done it and you and i wouldn't do it now
either but
somebody might try to lead us to do it
but but younger people in the industry
i mean really smart perceptive people
they their conversations
are built that way because that's what
they've heard and done all their lives
so it'd be interesting i i mean text
richard and jay and
and ask both in that but i yeah i
believe those guys are pretty sincere
about what they do not about themselves
but what they do
do you think lebron was the pippen to
dwayne wade's
jordan in miami no but but that
no i don't but i think that
dwayne wade and lebron were equals in
some ways
where michael and scotty in terms of
just basketball
were not i mean the pecking order was
established as michael jordan and
scottie pippen you know
you know and also starring scottie
pippen
dwyane wade had won a championship
before lebron got there yeah
dwyane wade came one injured rib
thing late in that game at the previous
year from getting to the finals and
beating detroit remember they lost in
game seven i think you and i were
in that little vomitorium uh in in miami
that happened so
i you know no dwyane wade to me and i
i'll admit my bias being a south side
chicago guy as is dwyane wade he's one
of my favorite players
ever dwyane wade and lebron particularly
before
they won their first championship in
year two of that four year ride
i to me they were pretty much equals
i know lebron will go down as the
greater player in history i get that
but at that time dwayne waded one lebron
james said
and lebron james why did he hook up with
dwyane wade why did he go somewhere else
pick up somebody else
dwyane wade had something he knew he
could he could share in and be with and
be
partners part full equal partners to me
at that time
he's michael wilbon pardon the
interruption co-host nba analyst steve
nash
going to the nets how big is surprise
huge huge
my son was my 12 year old son was think
he's my producer now he knows what time
i wake up obviously
as you do and it's just every morning
now there's some tap on the shoulder dad
wake up
and there's some news so yesterday
dan he he said dad wake up who do you
think is the new coach of the nets
and i i could have gone 150 names
more i could have gone 300 names before
i got to steve nashville i
love steve nash is one of my favorite
players ever
i i wouldn't have gotten to steve nash
now i wasn't aware of the relationship
with kevin durant
let's face it those things shaped
everything now in every sport
but particularly the nba and there you
know there's a list of guys who have
guards particularly you know our friend
and colleague mark jackson
you know the guys who have walked
straight out never been coaches
either from radio or television or
whatever larry bird had never coached
doc rivers you know had never coached
isaiah
um you know so i i'm shocked
i'm shocked weren't you i couldn't yeah
yesterday because i was traveling
were you weren't you shocked yes my guys
did the same to me they go the nets
have announced their next head coach and
then they go do you want to guess
the only way i guessed it i said okay
hall of famer
and then i was told yes hall of famer
and then i said give me something else
a big soccer fan oh well there you go i
go steve
nash is the coach of the nets and then
i i mean i don't i think it's great that
he kept
jacques vaughn i think that's really
important for him
and you know even if you're going to add
some reggie miller said that he would
add
alvin gentry like you gotta you gotta
insulate steve a little bit with guys
who've been through the ringer here yeah
and guys then
he trusts and has a relationship which
of course he does already with alvin
gentry he approached him yeah
you are yes the ensemble is very
important
for a lot of reasons but i wow
i mean that's a while you know what the
pressure on them going in
i mean first of all in that city and
people can say well the knicks
of course the knicks are the number one
team there but then they don't even
matter the knicks is not gonna matter
next year the knicks don't count
the knicks aren't gonna be on the back
page unless it's something that dolan's
done that's stupid
so man the brooklyn nets start off with
um and kyrie is such a wild card no
matter what the relationship is with
kevin durant they just start to me
with as much pressure as anybody in the
east except
onto kumpo they may vault the sixers
for pressure in the east depending on
who the sixers wind up
hiring as coach we were just talking
about this we had a listener
jeff in detroit who brought up a
question who has the most to gain this
year
tom brady with the title or lebron with
the title
oh oh that's good um
lebron yeah that's what i think i said i
don't even know the tom bricks already
so
far out here in the you know saturn's
rings
i'm not sure you know and even even with
lebron and i i'm never going to say
lebron is
better than michael jordan or as good as
and that's not going to happen for me
how many while i have lebron on my mount
rushmore i'm not putting them with
mike michael his his legacy set too as
far as i'm concerned but it could be
enhanced
a little by a championship with a third
team that that
that'd be pretty big deal who has more
rings saturn or tom brady
[Laughter]
yeah i mean you know what they're gonna
have some pressure now too
they're so loaded and dan why aren't
these other teams trying
why didn't why why is it that they
appear to not be trying as hard
as tampa and i you know i i tony and i
have a bet
i'm taking bill belichick and cam newton
to have more wins
than tom brady okay and i know i'm
probably in the 15 to 20
group on that that's probably 80 plus
that are saying no they'll take tom
brady i'll take bill belichick mike
that's a hot take right there
or or just two old guys sitting around
having an opinion
i know i don't know how it just became
hey that's my opinion too that's a hot
take
i'll take pac mark the marketing people
you know i hate the marketing people
i hate them all the ones i work for
uh six days until the nfl season
the number one storyline going
into the season is what other than brady
let's say
well the first one to me is can they get
through it what's it gonna look like
oh so you would say corona or social
justice
yeah yeah can they get through it and
and some of the side lights
and you know if the focus is going to
auto it's going to go very quickly to
jerry jones
who has been hiding under a desk most of
the summer
uh who can run his mouth whenever it is
easy
but when it's difficult can't be found
i hate guys like that and i you know i
i'm not a guy who hates jerry jones i
i think jerry jones is good for sport
he's good for business he's certainly
good for the business of the nfl
but his so his performance this summer's
been pretty disgraceful
to me that's judgment yes
but if we're talking about on field
stuff
i think it becomes at the beginning dan
i think we're looking at
we're all going to look at brady
belichick outside of our local
circumstance
for me it's can the bears after 101
years of competition find a quarterback
yet
i mean it's because there's been sid
luckman and jim mcmahon
in a hundred years and now we got
you know we got these two guys and
neggie's not gonna announce the starter
that probably means we still don't have
a starter the quarterback to me is still
jim mcmahon
i can find him on a golf course in
scottsdale anytime i want
and i just that's for me i mean i think
i think these things are very local
still in the nfl at least to start the
season two weeks in
if the bears are owen two it you know it
becomes something else you shift your
focus and you know aaron rodgers
is certainly you know aaron rodgers that
whole thing is oh that's
sneaky that's a sneaky can you imagine
if the packers don't make the playoffs
oh my god are we looking aren't we
looking at joe montana and kansas city
aren't we looking at that joe montana
steve young
depending on what the what love does
this season in practice and whether he
impresses his coaches
jordan love is not ready no anytime soon
and i think that's why aaron rodgers
gets two years
if he wants him well if you're aaron
rodgers do you say you know what
you really love this guy let me see how
much you love this guy
yes i'm gonna i'm gonna leave it's like
somebody's going steady with you
just because they want to have a
girlfriend and then they're just waiting
for that other girl to break up with her
boyfriend and then you're going to go
with
i would just expedite this and just say
well i think rogers can just make that
call
and so i listen suppose they go south
could it happen sooner i'm not saying a
mid-season thing is going to happen
just by the time we get to the end of
this season whenever it is or whatever
it looks like
like is aaron rodgers is that is that a
divorce
already are they are they you know just
consulting each other's attorneys
is that what they're doing i i could see
that but i don't i don't know man it's
kind of hard for me to think that aaron
rodgers is gonna put up with that soap
opera
for two years if he's playing like the
aaron rodgers of last year i wouldn't if
i was him
well plus they didn't get him any
weapons they got him a fullback and
another running back
and he didn't and receivers have been
out there look
first of all the packers just could have
called jacksonville and said look we'd
like two or three of your guys can you
send them up we'll send a plane for them
to help aaron rodgers and they haven't
done that
and if i was aaron rodgers i'd be
frosted i would be everywhere i'm aaron
rodgers is my this is tough for a bear's
guy
aaron rodgers is my favorite quarterback
other than not even other than
probably ever certainly the last 25
years
my favorite guy not saying the best guy
my favorite
and so to see him have to put up with
this is just insane
would you give up a month's pay for
aaron rodgers to be the quarterback of
the bears
can i talk you down in three weeks
two weeks that's almost a yes two weeks
without a paycheck for aaron rodgers
yeah
you know what as great as rogers is he
couldn't overcome the bearers mike
you don't think so you know quarterbacks
and wide receivers go
and die in chicago they do
they do look they do i tell people all
the time and they start talking about
quarterbacks
i said we don't know anything about that
i grew up i don't know anything about
that i
followed this team followed it for 55
years
i know about linebackers i know about
running backs
i know about sinners i may even know
about great offense other offensive
lineman tackles
because there's some hall of famers
jimbo covert and others
but we don't know about we don't know
about quarterbacks and it's not in our
dna we know
nothing of it which is why i go back to
sid luckman
and jim mcmahon how about that good to
visit with you how's the golf game by
the way
um better you know i'm i'm working with
someone who people
who are social media golf folks know
tanya tyree is her last name it's her
name
um and tanya is from new zealand been a
professional golfer
um and is on social media everywhere
trick shots and
and specialty stuff and we ran into each
other at an event in arizona
and she said she could take me on and
help me and she has
i'm not ready for you yet for crying out
loud yeah
but you know what are you doing in the
single digits now can you beat barkley
yes but that's the death the bar is not
charles charles is going to kill me for
saying that as you know me in trouble
uh good to visit with you have a good
weekend there mike thanks thanks man
nice
appreciate it mike wilbon from wilben
from pardon the interruption